work is underway to prepare the
remaining part of the collapsed
apartment building in miami for
demolition
with a storm approaching the area the
structure has been deemed
too unstable meanwhile the search and
rescue mission at the site has been
suspended while preparations go ahead
authorities say the mission will resume
when the demolition has been completed
for over a week the families of those
still missing in surfside have been
waiting in vain for news of their loved
ones
now they face another excruciating delay
to the recovery operation
as demolition teams prepare to carry out
a controlled explosion
at the site
we're proceeding with our evaluation of
all of the factors
all of the time and the impacts related
to the demolition
of the building while the search and
rescue continues as our top
priority with tropical storm elsa
forecasts to make landfall in florida in
the coming days
officials decided the rest of the
collapse complex needs to come down fast
tropical storm elsa has now become
hurricane
elsa and we are working i've
ordered our department of emergency
management to start preparing
a potential state of emergency the
instability of the site has been a major
challenge for the search operation
it was already forced to pause for
almost 24 hours on thursday
after dangerous movement was detected in
the debris
it's hoped the demolition will reduce
the dangers faced by the crews
when they resume combing through the
rubble
and that the families now living in
limbo will soon have certainty
about the fates of their loved ones
you